thomas ich hätte nicht für möglich
gehalten dass nach david graf wieder
noch mal was kommen kann
was war in der anlass also war es
sozusagen dieses letzte jahr es
beschreibt das so es nach heilig alles
wunderbar aber plötzlich wurz holprig in
der zweiten lebenshälfte
es wurde ja auch in der zweiten hälfte
des buches holpriger ich hab das buch ja
nicht als lebensbeichte angelegt sondern
diese biografie lief ganz gut mein leben
war erzählt und ich habe auch dieses
buch ja ein bisschen als abschluss
geplant gab dieses herbst blond er habe
ich gedacht danach lege ich die füße
hoch fernsehen hat sich erledigt das
fragen sie wie ich es kannte also das
ddr-fernsehen das samstagabend fernsehen
also meine welt lag in trümmern und ich
habe gedacht ich lege auch in trümmern
also das ist ein guter zeitpunkt
aufzuhören
da war ich so um die 60 und dann hat
sich plötzlich tatsächlich
herausgestellt dass man noch wünsche
interessen man zuckt noch über 60 und
ich hab mir das buch ja nicht ausgedacht
für menschen um die 30 um ihnen zu
erklären die schönes werden als zu
werden sondern für menschen meines
alters die einfach sich damit abfinden
müssen dass der rücken weh tut dass man
nicht mehr alles checkt wie es war und
dass man plötzlich sich auch umgeben
sieht von einer welt die man nicht mehr
versteht das ist ja das problem und ich
muss sagen
nachdem ich ihnen gehört habt und demut
ist ein wort das ich relativ selten in
den mund nehmen
das ist eine ganz andere biografie ich
hatte so eine ungebrochene und
traumatisierte biografie ich habe mir
mit den beatles und mit woodstock und
mit love and peace mein leben schön
gedacht und es gab nichts was mich so
richtig aus der bahn geworfen hätte
das alter war das erste und das alter
habe ich ja nun nicht zur kenntnis
genommen sondern das hat mich plötzlich
entdeckt und ich habe gerade im himmel
sehen was ist da los ich treffe
politiker in eine in einer talkrunde mit
politikern welche nieder älteste gewesen
heute bin ich begrüße ich also es war
einfach so
ich treffe chefärzte und ich treffe ich
treffe programmdirektoren die die jünger
sind als ich so was ist denn da passiert
also das alte überfällt einen und das
ist etwas wo man im grunde anfängt seine
zeit ernster zu nehmen ich habe meinem
buch auch vieles geschrieben
absichtserklärungen sind also dass ich
das ich ehrlich mit mir werde mit mir
schon mit mir kann ich persönlich gut
reden aber die tatsache die ich war mein
ganzes leben lang eigentlich jetzt sind
wir wieder bei der politik ein populist
von berufswegen ich wollte immer dass
ich möglichst wenig widerspruch erwecke
sonst hätten die leute abgeschaltet und
ich wollte dass mein publikum von mir
immer das hört was es am liebsten wär
das ist sinn des fernseh royal das ja
ich wollte geliebt werden und ich musste
wenn nicht geliebt werden wollte nur auf
die straße gehen tommy also das war im
grunde natürlich eine sehr komfortable
situation manchmal bewusst gemacht auf
die straße und wurde so dass man dass
man das so sucht dieses die dieses bad
und diese zuneigung die dir so entgegen
gekommen ist wie sie glaube ich wenig
anderen menschen jemals entgegen man
sucht sie nicht aber man braucht sie
irgendwie mehr als man denkt ich habe
auch gedacht wenn ich in malibu die füße
hoch und keine sau nicht mehr kennt ist
das alles gut ich habe genügend
zuneigung zuspruch erfahren es ist jetzt
nicht so dass ich sage ich habe mich
getäuscht und ich warte jetzt bewusst in
der menge aber es ist so dass ich meinen
beruf natürlich mit einer großen liebe
ausgeübt habe auch das muss ich wirklich
sagen ohne zu kokettieren mit liebe zu
meinem publikum es hat niemanden gegeben
in meiner ganzen laufbahn wenig unwirsch
abgefertigt hätte weil er mir sagen
wollt er hat die und die sendung wird
weil er ein autogramm wollte oder weil
er das was ich gemacht habe
gut gefunden hat dazu habe ich sehr
gemacht und ich war nie einer der am
samstagabend um 20 15 dollar nach
eingeschaltet hat und am montag
miesepetrig durch die welt marschiert
deswegen ist es mir so leicht gefallen
und deswegen schreibe ich natürlich auch
in einer sagen wir mal fröhlichen
gesamtstimmung und habe auch immer
versucht alles das war mir an was mir an
widrigkeiten im leben begegnet ist mit
dieser grundhaltung zu nehmen und dem so
zu begegnen und des handelns immer
eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert und
trotzdem liest man da oder höchstens
eine nachdenklichkeit
69 wohl langsam zeit aber auch so so so
so setzte die zum beispiel ich habe
manchmal nur drauflos geplaudert anstatt
wirklich was zu sagen und manchmal habe
ich nicht das gesagt was ich gedacht
habe und hätte sagen sollen
an welchen stellen zum beispiel an den
stellen wo ich gemerkt hätte das kostet
mich jetzt zuneigung oder aber auch und
das war das schlimmere das könnte
missverstanden werden heute ist es mehr
die angst missverstanden zu werden
die leichtigkeit mit der man als
30-jähriger über eierstöcke redet die
ist heute nicht mehr gegeben also ich
habe ich habe auch schon mal gemacht
hast du denn die wenigen die es nicht
wissen ja ich habe oft dummes zeug
erzählt und ich wusste ich komme damit
davon weil ich war es ja und heute gibt
es diese gnade nicht mehr dass man sagen
kann kommt der gott lass ihn reden
dermaßen lasst ihn doch reden sondern es
wird im wesentlichen jeder mit dingen
konfrontieren für die er gar nichts kann
er muss ich er muss sich für dinge
entschuldigen oder er muss dinge
erklären die er gar nicht erklären kann
weil er eben politik ist erklär uns das
gefälligst und ich bin heute auch in
eine situation wie ich habe das nur
gesagt aber was ich gemeint habe das
geht doch kein haus ahnten aber so habe
ich das nicht gelesen
da geht es um etwas anderes da geht es
ja um die frage an welcher stelle man im
leben möglicherweise schon für arbeit
kommt
also bbx so bleibt ihnen etwas aufregen
ich zitiere nur aus dem buch ich habe so
oft ja gesagt im leben und ich habe zu
oft geschwiegen bin von natur aus nicht
auf krawall gebürstet ich möchte geliebt
werden und sagst jetzt ist gibt's neues
ziel für das letzte lebens drittel so
schreibst du wahrhaftig zu sein genau
was wir auf dieses ziel gehe ich langsam
zu wenn ich da bin melde ich mich wieder
das heißt für das wahrhaft stück zu
sagen das heißt das heißt das muss man
die wahrhaftigkeit heißt auch in der
lage sein unangenehme dinge zu sagen und
auch menschen letzten endes vor den kopf
zu stoßen deswegen konnte ich ja kein
politiker werden weil ich immer mein
heil in der frohen botschaft gesucht
habe und nicht in der in der
unangenehmen wahrheit und verhalten sind
oft unangenehm und das habe ich in
letzter zeit eben festgestellt wenn dir
das haus weg brennt ist das eine
unangenehme wahrheit du musst dich aber
auch mit dem auseinandersetzen was
dieses haus für dich irgendwann bedeutet
hat was es noch bedeutet also
unverändert bei dir diese diese hat
dieser brand zum beispiel plötzlich
alles in rauch aufgeht das ding sich
dafür ein letztes lebensjahr
ich habe mir mein ganzes leben lang
schön moderiert ich habe wenn es nicht
so war wie ich wollte es mir eben ein
geredet aber es gibt häuser kannst du
dir nicht mehr einreden ich habe das
lange genug versucht ich bin ja ich bin
hier um die ecke gefahren da stand
dieses haus aber eben nur noch in meinem
hirn weil es da immer stand es du musst
dich aber damit auseinandersetzen dass
es da eben nicht mehr steht und die
konsequenzen die sich daraus ergeben
tragen und das war für mich neu aber es
musste dieses disruptive was ihr heute
alle wollen als plötzlich die irgendwie
der boden unter den füßen weggezogen
wird das konnte ich bis ins hohe alter
verhindern jetzt eben nicht mehr
deswegen noch mal die frage was hat das
bei dir aus gips und ganz kurzen und da
sind wir wieder bei social media video
schnipsel glaube ich sogar auf dem genau
dein haus deine mühle brennt aufgenommen
vom nachbarn wo hast du das gesehen dass
hier
da habe ich gedacht dass mich die
windmühle dobrindt wir uns anderes aber
es war sie dann doch also das heißt ich
habe mich lange genug damit getröstet
dass das kann nicht ich sein die können
nicht mich meinen aber es war dann
tatsächlich meine mühle
nichtsdestotrotz es ist eben einfach die
fähigkeit sich mit unangenehmen dingen
auseinanderzusetzen die muss man
erlernen sie hat sie früh in ihrem leben
erlernten es hat sehr früh
das habe ich jetzt gerade eben
mitbekommen
auch gelernt sich nicht nur damit
auseinanderzusetzen sondern für sich
daraus konsequenzen abzuleiten
das musste ich nie tun ich habe immer im
radio gemacht ich hab fernsehen gemacht
ich habe nie an einem casting
teilgenommen weil ich alles das was ich
machen wollte haben sie mir irgendwie
freiwillig gegeben jahr weil ja weil wir
sind alle im grunde mit ihr aufgewachsen
das macht dich jetzt älter als du bist
so ist das gar nicht gemeint ich habe
gleich wieder dazwischen die ist aber da
war ein neuer sound das hat er so eine
leichtigkeit und seine lässigkeit die es
vorher nicht gab
dass da so habe mein ganzes leben drin
ist lag an den anderen teams bis dahin
gemacht hatten
wenn du dieses haus dir nochmal
anschauen ich meine die die geschichte
dieses hauses wie es damals dazu
gekommen was war die seite du warst doch
in england zu dem zeitpunkt dann bevor
er nach ja nach malibu gegangen sagt
einmal kurz die geschichte man sieht ja
schon dass das dass das nichts normales
ist und als wir dieses haus das er ein
verrückt der engländer hat da in den in
den 80er jahren man dachte immer das war
1920 oder so diese windmühle dahin
gesetzt und hat da dieses zeug rum
umgebaut und wir sind da ein gekommen
und da waren ja schon 30 amerikaner drin
die das alle nicht wolken haben wird um
gottes willen das so aus als wäre die
addams family gerade ausgezogen
und wir haben gesagt das machen wir das
tannheimer wo das wasser getropft ist
aber das war eine challenge das waren
das bahnprojekt wie man da sagt und da
habe ich mich dem habe ich mich gestellt
und das war auch meine heimat das wurde
mir dann zur heimat es ist auch ein
absoluter traum den sich weniger
erfüllen konnten
und ich habe mit diesen traum erfüllt
mit mit gummibären und banker wetten das
muss man mal nachmachen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
thema heimat sagt thomas spielt auch
eine rolle machst dir gedanken über die
frage also für dich war immer klar was
heimat ist und du stellst in dem
zusammenhang die frage bei meinen söhnen
ist das nicht unbedingt so klar warum
nicht
weil ich eben und das ist dass in dieser
unkomplizierten welt groß geworden bin
ich habe keine möglichkeit gehabt mich
mit meinem smartphone am abendessen
tisch aus der wirklichkeit zu entfernen
indem ich mich in die weite welt
gegoogelt habe oder dem ich bin ich
jemandem irgendwo gefolgt bin dass da
frau kardashian gerade in amerika sitzt
und sich den hintern polstert hat mich
in kulmbach nicht interessiert ich habe
meine mutter hat gesagt dass hacker wird
gegessen da gab es so zermatscht
ölsardinen ich habe das gehasst und wenn
man dazu wenn man es tee getrunken hat
war das ganz furchtbar das war meine
welt und in meinem garten standen
apfelbaum und ich saßen oben im
apfelbaum und hab gedacht irgendetwas
wird man mal aus mir und und als ich
meinem sohn gezeigt habe dass ist der
apfelbaum wo ich immer sagt da bin ich
ihm hoch geklettert wie gesagt nicht
warum also ein
[Applaus]
also und diese unkomplizierte welt ich
wusste egal was in mathe läuft egal
welche pickel mich befallen hatten wenn
ich um 21 uhr mit meinem neckermann
radio im bett lag und mit ihm über den
kopf gezogen habe da war tony prince zu
hören von radio luxemburg ich war ihr
tony prince und das ist etwas wo ich
sage ich habe in irgendeiner form mit
einer gewissen leichtigkeit menschen
mitgenommen das war ein großes glück und
die ich war jetzt letzte woche beim
rammstein-konzert übergeben müssten
nicht im dunkeln begegnen
er kam auf mich zu sowas gibts doch gar
nicht mehr
[Applaus]
am start sind sehr eindeutig sind die
eltern dürfen mehr brandverletzungen
erwartet wer ist eigentlich viel erkannt
noch auch von jungen leuten gut und das
ist ja auch wichtig weil es nicht aber
ich springe hinter die nächste säule
wenn eine wenn einer mir entgegenkommt
denkmal neuer ist natürlich lebst du
dass die ganz jungen wie kommen die
heute auf dich zu naja schneller ist
[Applaus]
und rechen die ich nie an woher kennen
die dich ich frage mich woher kennst du
mich aber es ist diesem grunde sagen die
am meisten
die einen sehen mich natürlich als
coolen oper und die andere sagen ich bin
mit ihr groß geworden die einen kennen
sich von den goldbären die anerkennung
nicht vom fernsehen ist mir egal ob sie
kennen deine söhne
kindererziehung ist auch ist auch so ein
thema in diesem buch mit dem du dich
auch ist er nachdenklich beschäftigt
sich mit der frage was hat man falsch
gemacht ist man viel zu lässig ist man
für das alles sind so der
wohlstandsverwahrlosung wie vegeta deine
antwort wie lautet deine antwort darauf
also es hat keinen sinn den kindern eine
wirklichkeit eine feine eine fremde
wirklichkeit einreden zu wollen also wir
sind arm und wir haben wir können uns
kein iphone leisten und wir spielen mit
mit mit holz gegenständen aus dem
riesengebirge sondern das war zu meiner
zeit waren dass irgendwelche remains
oder weiß der teufel und ich habe schon
gewusst da kann ich gescheit ist raus
werden also dem dem skelett ohr da kann
es ja aber irgendwie so gut zu meiner
zeit war dass der teufel und
grundsätzlich ist es eben so dass dieses
komplizierte was ja immer schlimmer
würde
zu meiner zeit noch relativ im griff
zahlt war also beim oh mann da war
konnte ich noch mit mit dem kleinen
wassermann ich habe also von otfried
preußler in den kleinen wassermann
den habe ich meinen söhnen vorgelesen
hier lese ich in meinem enkel vor und
und enkel hat mittlerweile zwei soweit
ich weiss zwar ja okay und und das ist
schon unterschiedlich also ich hab diese
reise auf dem kopf - durch diesen
mühlteich empfand ich noch als was
romantisches endlich mal ein kind heute
was einmütig ist google den sofort ist
es war beschreibst du sagst da geht es
ja auch um heimat also in kalifornien zu
sitzen und grimmsche märchen vorzulesen
das waren wir immer klar das wird nicht
funktionieren soll ist auf englisch vor
gram sales zwischen horror story aber
hast du dann also deutsches kulturgut
aber kann man da nicht so richtig
transportiere sagte mir war es nicht als
deutsche kommen nicht mit dem rücken
jetzt aber also der ist deutscher
verbrannt haben ja als das deutsche
kulturgut war mir wurscht in hollywood
also ich habe gesagt ich ziehe meine
kinder so dass
halbwegs normal werden und das ist mir
geglückt dass ich halbwegs normale
kinder die schon ein kunststück an sich
trotzdem du warst immer der der die
familie zusammengehalten hat den das
auch wichtig war diese familie
zusammenzuhalten sehr katholisch geprägt
und so weiter haben uns jemand
ausführlich auch darüber unterhalten
auch deine deine ehe dann eine sehr sehr
lange ehe mit e haben plötzlich lese ich
in der zeitung thomas gottschalk
getrennt das wetter ist das habe ich in
meinem kopf nicht so richtig zusammen
gekriegt das ist auch eine eine
schwerwiegende zensur in einem leben die
man weder einem journalisten irgendeine
einer frauen zeitung erklären kann noch
einem sensiblen markus lanz das sind
nein das ist einfach so es gibt dinge
die passieren auch wenn du sie nicht für
möglich gehalten hättest mir ist das
eben passiert und ich muss damit umgehen
und du wirst natürlich wenn du merkst
die strecke die du noch zu leben hast
wird kürzer etwas wagemutiger und und
diesen wagen den ich mir mein leben lang
nicht gegönnt habe den habe ich mir
jetzt letztendlich dann gegönnt und habe
neulich auch gewagt zu sagen sicher ist
man sich ja nie dann dann haben meine
neue lebensgefährtin zwölf journalisten
angerufen der sich gar nicht sicher was
möchten sie dazu sagen sind sie haben
sie eine krise da dann wirst du was
kriege ich die krise verstehen weil das
ist so sensibel und das ist natürlich
etwas was menschen sei es meine kinder
sei es meine frau im tiefsten inneren
trifft auch nicht und dann war schluss
du dich durch und diese behauptung dass
es menschen gibt die sich nicht
irgendwie durchwurschteln die halte ich
für unsinnig wir versuchen alle alle
halbwegs werden sie wollen ganz klar zu
kommen und ich habe natürlich auch immer
gedacht na ja wenn es wenn es ein
bisschen steinig wurde auf dem weg
irgendwann steht da der petrus am
himmelstor mit dem fleißkärtchen und
sagt hier ist alles hier ist sozusagen
also dein ticket dass ich scheiße was
mache ich wenn er da nicht steht dann
dann leisten sonst irgendwann ich eben
alles umsonst haben und es war ja alles
richtig ich sage ja nicht mein gott was
habe ich für fehler gemacht ich habe das
habe ich gerade vorher als ihnen das
gesprochen hat wieder gemerkt
ein so durchgängiges glückliches
geradezu harmloses leben gehabt dass ich
also dass die aufregung jetzt gut
vertragen kann ich habe mich geschont
ich habe mich gefragt was hat das damit
zu tun dass das dass diese mühle
abgebrannt ist dass man irgendwann
radikaler wird und sagt weißt du was
jetzt jetzt gibt noch mal zurück auf los
jetzt waren wir noch mal von vorne an
so ist loslassen ist auch loslassen
vielleicht aber dass das weißt du das
ist man kommt da sehr schnell arrogant
daher man kommt sehr schnell flap sich
daher ein mensch ein ich bin ich würde
sagen ich denke durchaus viel nach über
mich oder über den rest der welt
hauptsächlich über mich und und damit
hast du schon genug zu tun deswegen habe
ich ja auch nie versucht den rest der
welt zu retten sondern immer mich und
meine familie nicht mal das ist mir über
die über die weite strecke gelungen aber
trotzdem sage ich ich möchte versuchen
schäden die ich an richtete so gering
wie möglich zu halten ich möchte
versuchen für mich in anspruch zu nehmen
dass ich weiß was ich tue ich bin ich
bin kein trottel der der plötzlich mit
mit ende 60 denkt mein heil liegt in der
gründung einer neuen ehe mit einer 27
jährigen balletttänzerin was auch immer
ich rechne ich denke ich versuche und
ich habe eben einfach einen entschluss
gefällt der für viele nicht
nachvollziehbar ist sondern sage ich ist
mir egal hauptsache für mich ist
nachvollziehbar
das ist ja
du bist du bist da so eine instanz und
ihr vater immer so eine instanz und
ehrlich gesagt reden wir auch gerade
auch in dieser sendung nie über solche
dinge aber du machst das in deinem buch
zum thema ist auch in vielen interviews
jetzt auch darüber gesprochen und ich
habe mich gefragt warum man merkt dass
du nicht willst auf eine art und weise
und das gefühl hast dich erklären zu
müssen aber ja weylandt war ich mein
ganzes leben lang irgendwo ein
öffentlicher mensch war und das problem
ist ist der durchlauferhitzer wenn mich
ein taxifahrer anspricht und sagt du
passt mal auf ich bin 30 erwartet bei
mir war kids was soll ich machen erzähl
ich dem alles ich bin gegen eine dame
von in einem magazin kommt und sagt
unsere leser wollen so gerne wissen sie
machen sich solche sorgen sage ich du
dumme nuss du willst deine zeitung du
willst eine zeitung verkaufen es ist mir
völlig egal was in meinem leben passiert
ja es passt sehr gut in den kram bei
prinz harry gerade schwächelt und weil
und weil dieter bohlen gerade im urlaub
ist also jetzt bin ich dran und dass
deswegen habe ich plötzlich wärmste
gefühle zur verliehene fischer weil
diese arme dieser arme luft turner der
dann plötzlich irgendwo sie liebt und
zwar aus vollem herzen der dann nicht
versteht dass ihnen frau mit herz oder
oder das blaue das grüne was es da
gerade gibt durch die mangel nimmt dann
sagte ich rede mit der zeit die zeit
hätte mit dem die gesprochen und er die
mit der zeit aber dass das was in der
zeit steht dann bei denen auch ankommt
so weit denkt er nicht
und dann oh gott ich und du bist ja
heute ich will mich aufregen
also ich da unten von deiner von 300 tür
steht immer freundliche menschen mit mit
autogrammen tommy hier tommy da und
haben fotos die ich nie gesehen habe in
meinem ganzen leben von mir und einer
steht dabei der plötzlich sagt sind sie
glücklich sind wo sie gut so wollte ich
gerade anfangen dann merke ich das ja so
eine kleine kamera hat hätte ich denen
gesagt wie glücklich ich bin wer ich
irgendeine magazin sogar zdf irgendwo
anders wir verkaufen den ganzen mist das
heißt du bist eben nicht mehr der der
privatmensch der do x mas und ich
erzähle jedem dem ich helfen kann über
kindererziehung über eheprobleme über
schlaflosigkeit weil ich sage wenn du
das problem aber ich jetzt jedoch nicht
der apotheken rundschau meine
schlaflosigkeit
wie reagiert in der taxifahrer
[Applaus]
der taxifahrer reagiert sodass er sagt
da wusste ich dass sie meine frau so das
ist genau das und jeder taxifahrer ist
anders und mit der taxifahrer aus
afghanistan kommt erkläre ich den das
genau so werden aus milbertshofen kommt
und das ist ja mein großes glück dass
sie mich beide fragen und ich habe von
taxifahrern aus afghanistan mehr über
den afghanistan konflikt gelernt als ich
jemals spiele gelesen habe das ist eben
wenn man mit den menschen redet wenn du
wenn du mit bin wenn du das habe ich
habe dieses kommunikative und ich mag
menschen und erfreulicherweise mögen sie
auch mich da scheint miteinander zu tun
zu haben
und es gibt aber dinge wo ich sage davon
verstehe ich nichts mehr und ich merke
eben heute dass ich auch von teilen der
welt nichts mehr wissen ich habe mich ja
bei twitter verrannt in die nummer weil
ich fand es plötzlich toll da haben sich
die kollegen vom spiegel sogar gelobt
und sagten gottschalk da findet sich
gerade auf twitter neu und das gab
natürlich noch mal gas
ich habe ich habe den dänen den flamingo
oder in meinem teilchen malibu
fotografierte ribler bloß sitzen ich
brauche irgendwas und und und das ist
das problem
weißt du denkst du kannst die ausbremsen
also jetzt habe ich plötzlich kann ich
in die welt setzen dass mein enkel
geboren ist so dachte ich das habe ich
doch gleich geschrieben und noch ein
kinderfoto dazu dass ich bin ich
bescheuert wenn irgendeiner mich fragt
von irgendeiner zeitung hast du ein
enkel solche die die drinnen stand du
fängst an selbst zu liefern und dann
gibt es irgendeinen follower in wanne
eickel tommy so geil wie du mich abholt
denke ich hole ich morgen wieder ab bin
ich eigentlich
und dann merkst du kannst dich dass du
in einer art bringschuld ich selber
sagen dass dann das unter druck gesetzt
sich selbst das sind ja nette menschen
das sind ja typen also ich hab ich habe
mein nachttisch irgendwann mal
fotografiert unterliegen wie
wahrscheinlich bei dir auch die august
die bekenntnisse von augustinus dann
schreibt irgendeiner augustin ist immer
noch die beste möglichkeit einzuschlafen
habe ich mit dem einen hoch die
sensiblen dialog angefangen da sind ja
nicht nur deppen unterwegs aber die
deppen kriegen es alle mit das ist dass
du öffnest heute und lässt leute rein
von den noch nie im leben möchtest dass
sie etwas mit dir zu tun haben
die du kannst ist nicht begrenzt wieder
zu dieser eingangsfrage von mir damit
macht ja zu zu machen wollte ich nie und
in dem moment wo deine ehe wackelt in
dem moment wo irgendetwas ist musst du
aufmachen in meinem leben und muss leute
rein lassen wo du sagst ich habe ich
gerade gebraucht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe das irgendwie ganz anders
gelesen ich habe immer gedacht also wenn
man wieder sagt die verheiratete und her
sie wird sich so das ist doch einfach
mal eine lebensleistung das muss man
erst mal hinkriegen als zwei kinder
großgezogen
eine 47 jahre verheiratet und so kann
man das doch neben und das hat man sich
neu verliebt sofort passiert viele
menschen auf dem planeten wo sie als man
denkt so und das größere berichtet mit
seiner frau besprechen und dann ist aber
auch indem wir haben das gar nicht -
reicher und 75 vertreter oder nein und
das ist ja genau dass er bei twitter
eventuelle nachteile sie wenig zu tun
und dann habe ich meine meine meine mir
zur verfügung stehenden buchstaben und
die mütze ich dann aber wenn du den
durchlauf werden plötzlich sich
psychologen hinsetzen und das ganze
werten wenn ein brandexperte dann meinen
meinen müll dann definiert und einfach
und einfach das ist das wo du sagen
kannst freunde so war es nicht lasst
mich damit den ruf können die gäste hier
so eine letzte frage noch thomas
bedeutet dass lebensmittelpunkt amerika
kalifornien erledigt du bist zurück in
deutschland
was weiß ich was meine zukunft bringt
der rilke ich lebe mein leben in
wachsenden ringen
ich bin im moment ein glücklicher mensch
es gibt menschen die mir mein glück
natürlich in irgendeiner form
ich will es nicht können aber es mir
erklären wollen warum ich warum ich
grund habe glücklich zu sein oder warum
ich keinen grund habe glücklich zu sein
ich versuche das eine der wenigen dinge
die ich mit mir selber abmachen ohne
fernsehen ohne kameras und ohne seine
kollegen von den medien
[Musik]
schönes design kann es nicht
was sagt dieses buch gibt es wirklich
also ich mache ja es gibt jetzt menschen
die sagen ja was ja nicht erzählt das
hat er vielleicht geschrieben kann so
seien meist mal nicht so genau
ich warte ja auf die fortsetzung nach
herbst blond jetzt herbst bund wäre
ahmad schachmatt herbst grau aber da
gibt es also am titel wird es nicht
scheitern am inhalt höchsten dank der
sehr thomas freue mich dich glücklich zu
sehen das ist schön